[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
この qr コードを読ましてください
皆さん簡単に埋めたでしょうか
スマートフォンを用いられる方
安心してください qr コードにはこのようなメッセージが入っていました
皆さんは qr コードついてどれだけ知っていますか
これから qr コードの秘密をお話しします
qr コードは1994年に
愛知県の自動車部品メーカーで誕生しました
自動車業界では生産管理のためにバーコードを使用していました
1990年代に入ると部品点数が増え
多くの情報を扱うようになっていました
当時バーコードは20文字程度しか扱えないことから
製品を出荷する現場ではバーコードを10個ぐらいならべ
それを一つ一つ読ませていましたこれを1日に1万枚程度ゆましていたことから
非常に作業効率が悪くまた作業する人は大変疲れていました
これを見たとき私は多くの情報を扱うにはもうバーコードは限界と思い
バーコードに代わる次世代の行動を開発しました
それが qr コードです
持続工場では
バーコードが油で覚えてしまうと
データは低入力しなければなりません
もし間違ってデータを入れたならば
それまで入れたデータをすべてチェックしなければならず
作業する人にとっては大きな負担となっていました
そこで qr コードは汚れたり破損したりしても
正確に読めるようにしました
まとまった汚れですと
コードの面積の約60%
散らばった汚れスト約30%が汚れても読むことができます
また局面に印刷されたものや
スマートフォンで斜めから写した
歪んだ qr コードでも確実に読むことができます
汚れたり歪んだりすると間違ってもじゃないかと
皆さんは心配するかもしれませんが
200文字程度の qr コードなら
間違っても確率は
なんと中の-15ジョーです
これは1日に1億まいりました場合に約3万年に1回
間違って4か読まないかの隔離です
こうなるともう間違って読むことはないと言ってもいいですよね
qr コードの開発の一番のポイントは
価格の安い読み取り装置でも高速かつ確実に読めるようにしたことです
qr コードはバーコードに比べて構造が複雑で多くの情報を扱うことから
弓取り時間がかかるという課題がありました
読取装置に使うコンピューターの性能をあげれば解決しますが
そうすると読み取り装置が高価になり
qr コードを導入する上で
大きな負担となりますそこでコードに工夫を加えてやすい読み取り装置でもバーコード
以上の読み取りスピードを実現しました
このように
コードの周りに文字があるとコードと文字を区別し
コードだけを抽出するは難しく非常に時間がかかります
そこでで一番工夫したところは
コードと文字が簡単に区別できる特徴的な御印
ファインダーパターンをつけたことです
文字の特徴を調べるために世界でよく使われている
5つの言語の新聞や雑誌を調査しました
その結果
文字を構成する玄人資料の比率が1対1対3対1対1が極端に少ないことを発見しまし
た
そしてあらゆる角度で回転してもこの比率が得られる
ファインダーパターンを考えました
このファインダーパターンをコードの3コーナーに配置することによって
コードの位置大きさ
肩書きが瞬時にわかりやすい読み取り装置でも200文字程度の qr コードなら
0.0産業と高速に読み取りができるようになりました
しかしどんなに素晴らしい行動を開発しても
安心して使いやすい環境がなければ使ってはもらえません
そこで qr コードの主要公開し特許の権利を無視を提供することで誰でも自由に
安心して使えるような環境をつくりました
これらにより2002年に携帯電話に qr コード読み取り機能が搭載され世界中の
人が使うようになりました
そこで多くの人の困りごとを収集し対応するために新しい機能を搭載して
常に qr コードを進化させてきました
例えば企業の
機密情報や個人情報が扱えるように
暗号機能を搭載してスマートフォンで夢なくした qr コード
地形となどに使えるように印刷技術と組み合わせてコピー機で複製できない qr
コードを開発しました
これらにより
セキュリティオートでも使われるようになりました
皆さんはこの先どのように使われると思いますか
最近では
顔認証技術と組み合わせた個人認証システムでも使われていますので
ビデオでご紹介します
まず顔情報を qr コード化します
これが彼を情報の入った qr コードですこの qr コード
読取装置にただしカメラに映った顔と照合して本人確認ができます
企業の勤怠管理や
ドアの鍵としても使うことができます
このシールというのでは
顔写真によるなりすましが防げ
さらには
端末に個人情報を持たないことからセキュリティ上のリスクを大幅に低減することが
できます
今後は画像や映像が扱えるようにし特に医療分野で使ってもらいたいと思っています
自分のレントゲン写真や心電図の医療情報 qr コードにして常に携帯することで新
サイズや街中で急に倒れた場合でもすぐに適切な治療が受けられ1人でも多くの命を
救いたいと思っています
そして更に安心安全な社会に貢献できるように
進化させていきます
このように進化させてきた qr コードですか
開発してきた私が
一番大切にしてきたことはそれは
ユーザー視点です
常にユーザーが
安心で使いやすい構図と環境を作り
ユーザーの付加価値を追求してきました
いまご荘櫂してきた機能もすべてユーザーを第一に考えてきたからこそ生まれた技術
です
だからこそ qr コードはここまで普及し社会に欠かせない存在となりました
新しい技術は
社会を発展させる上で大きな可能性を秘めています
しかし技術だけでは社会には浸透しません
ユーザー視点がなければどんな技術の初戦絵に描いた餅です
ユーザー視点といっても
単にユーザーの声を聞くだけでなく
実際に使っている現場をよく観察することです
そしてジュウザの困りごとを根本から解決することです
皆さんもぜひユーザー視点でわくわくする未来づくりの旅に出てみてはどうでしょうか
ありがとうございました
あった
[拍手]